you need to figure out what your comfort
zone is on communicating there's only
three there's audio video and record and
this is gonna be the answer for so many
of us in here the question is which
format works for you and then what you
need to do is realize the following
everything is about perspective shift a
slight perspective shift you have to
give away all your best advice on social
media at scale I'm in Singapore for the
last 10 years
um my heart and my head is all about
Healthcare and how can we make
Healthcare and vitality really cool so
that we can move people to do something
about their health before they feel sick
so that's what I'm about and that's what
I would love to ask more
um of you
I mean and how and what is do you have a
business in that within that Realm
Iran I used to run a biotech company for
four years build and sold
and then because I'm not a doctor
um a lot of people who are coming to me
saying guys can you explain whatever my
doctor is saying in a simplistic way
um and that kind of became a theme so
a few months back I decided to be a
little bit more open about it and talk a
little bit more about social media I'm
sorry on social media have a lot of
health and what's important but
currently the social media component one
is very new There's No Business behind
it per se I'm not promoting any of the
stuff that I used to work on
understood okay next
Laura Laura in Kansas City say hi to
Gary hi Gary great to see you again
Laura Schmidt Chief positive person with
notes to self socks
um positive phrases like I am kind on
the toes and the bottom of the socks
made in the USA so excited to be back
um looking forward to hearing your
thoughts
great to see you again awesome Ned
Specter say hi
hey Gary appreciate uh being here
um from Minnesota moved to uh La worked
at CAA for a handful of years left to go
uh help manage the Jonas Brothers Demi
Lovato got into uh Brandon merchandise
and uh most recently into uh doing
content for our company so looking
forward to getting some strategy to
bring those uh together so I'm a big fan
good to see you
Chris and Ethan up in Southern New
Hampshire say hi hey Gary Gary great to
see you I'm really excited to have an
opportunity to talk to you
um
my name is Chris I own a restcom
basement Solutions we're a specialty
Home Improvement contractor specializing
in based on waterproofing and foundation
repair been in business for 27 years
really focused on growing
the organization uh
push through some top-line Revenue goals
over the past few years and now really
looking to kind of bring it to the next
level it's awesome Ethan's my drock yeah
I'm our content slash digital marketing
manager in-house
amazing you you couldn't you couldn't
have found a different angle you had to
stick the Brady Jersey right down my
mouth I mean like actually we do have a
solution for that which I'll take care
of right now so we got this made up
especially for you just to hang right up
here thank you took care of it so we'll
put that right here for you
so we we had a plan in place to deal
with that
I don't know if the guy's over in uh in
southern Massachusetts have a better
plan but uh what's going on over in
southern uh Massachusetts Nick in Austin
hey the good news is we don't really
care about football too much so we'll
root for the Jets party that's fine
um so I'm Nick this is my business
partner Austin we do Residential uh
Landscaping Maintenance so mowing lawn
care Leaf cleanups things like that
we've been in business eight years and
we're in Southeastern Mass
love it brother pleasure good to see you
guys you too David rappa
David
still with us hey Gary
um last time I saw you was at brunch
Bears uh not so long ago I remember so I
have an investment management firm now I
remember going to Capital Management
um
it's been all Word of Mouth marketing I
have a handful of family uh offices and
individual clients I serve them to the
best of my ability we've been at it for
I've been at it for 20 years but in this
instance in this company for seven
um and I've never really thought of
marketing uh on social media or social
media in general above and beyond
investing in the companies which we have
and and we listen to what you say and
where to look
um
but in the pandemic you mentioned uh
LinkedIn as a platform I think I
remember a couple years ago as an
underutilized platform and because I
wasn't seeing my clients and a big part
of you know the businesses seeing people
and going to lunches and dinners I
decided to start to post a little bit on
LinkedIn to just you know get in front
of people and I did get some good
response from my existing client base
that oh it's nice to hear you're like
you know thinking about this talking
about this so I thought that was an
interesting lead-in for me to kind of
press more and see if there's more for
me to do in social media
love it makes tons of sense
all right we got Jennifer also last but
not least Jennifer say hi
hey Gary super nice to meet you my name
is Jennifer Cannon I'm in Parkland
Florida
um I have a skin care company called MD
topicals and my fiance is a huge fan of
yours so he got me hooked in nfts he's
got a bunch of those I have a humble pie
I wish I had more
um and I wanted to really thank you
because well I follow all your advice
religiously and you changed my life with
chat GPT because as a startup there is
no budget to hire employees and I'm like
so much more productive because I'm a
horrible writer so chat gbt is like my
employee and he puts out all my content
with me and I'm just really excited to
get to be here today I love that I love
that it's a real pleasure
all right let's uh let's restack the
deck and go back to Kaz over in
Singapore Cass uh let's you got about
seven minutes let's get into it okay
perfect thank you Cass before you get
into it you know for everyone here like
this is the time to go very specific
like what's cool about this format we've
learned along the way is like people
Garner value out of other people's thing
but this is like one-on-one time
thank you so much perfect so my first
question is I'm super new at this
um social media terrifies me after
listening to Jeff I'm like oh my God I
had so much to learn but with that my
question is what my main thing how can
we make longevity and Healthcare cool
how can I craft my voice and my brand to
really support that in a long run
I think there's there's a couple things
with your situation I think there's two
variables there's one which is universal
to everybody here back to what David I
think has like a good understanding
about intuitively and I'm excited to get
to his part as well but this is for
everyone Nick Chris everybody
you always like there is no thing on
Earth not religion not the biggest bands
or pop stars that Ned was working with
not selling wine nothing could be
accomplished unless someone knows about
it it's not super complicated
you know that's why I've bet my my prime
years on building the biggest
infrastructure in the world to
understand at every moment
from a media standpoint from a creative
standpoint from what's happening in
popular culture standpoint where is the
underpriced and where is the overpriced
attention right so first cast like in
crafting your message
there's there's the need to understand
that and that's going to be Universal
for everyone here the second need is
what do you want to happen right so for
example if David was like I'm looking to
sell my practice in the next three years
all of a sudden the content he's putting
out on LinkedIn is very very different
and very targeted
than it would be if he's looking to
acquire so for all of you what I'm going
to be trying to figure out is where are
you what would you like to happen right
so I think you're in such an early stage
where you're willing to use your you're
you're starting the Journey of building
a personal brand but you know the
question becomes what is that personal
brand trying to accomplish right so
you've already had a business to exited
you may want to you know this is very
common people want to run the same
blueprint again slightly different with
all the new nuances other times people
want to go completely away from the last
exit and do something completely
different
the thing that's most important in your
situation is I don't need you to know
yet you may not need to know where to
put this energy of longevity like you
can imagine you know uh for example back
to Lara like bringing kindness to the
world can be in the format of a personal
brand like me or it could be in the form
of socks that say positive and things
like you can put all of our energies
when I get to Ned when you know when I
get to you know Nick and crew like like
the energy can be put into anything
right so I think for you the questions
are a couple things
do you have what you want the next
business to be figured out product
service event business and so I'm gonna
go right to there do you yet or do you
have some running hypotheses because
it's going to impact the advice but the
good news is I don't need you to have
that figured out because the advice and
the work you have to do to even without
that being answered is quite substantial
we'll get into that in a second but
that's the first question
so the answer is not fully what is kind
of a slowly started happening is that
because of my background and also
um my pre-health prebiotech world was
all finance and investment
I was invited to multiple companies just
to speak to their
these sweet people basically how to feel
better on a daily basis because I don't
I'm not a doctor I don't speak doctor
and I simplify things
um so that kind of it became almost like
an
like I didn't think that would be a
thing but suddenly from one company to
another to another but it's not a
business line by any means at the state
and I have no idea
um I think it's an interesting I I for
example
I could have instead of building what
I'm building easily on a bad day built
an eight-figure income per year doing
that
right like when cons you know building a
one-woman show
that works with sweet the c-suite that
over a period of time has seven
employees and does 10 million dollars in
revenue on 70 margin 60 margin is very
realistic especially in the category
that you're playing because every future
c-suite executive is only going to care
more about mental and physical health it
is just the cat is so out of the bag
right it's like that is a runaway train
it's all going to be around the gray and
the EQ and the not black and white
do you want that do you think or do you
want to build something with more scale
that's less on your back
um good question the the initial feeling
I was having when I was giving
um those talks is
I can really see people just something
moving and it's not even because I'm not
even I'm not exactly giving them
something they don't know about maybe a
few tweaks here and there because
everything else literally you can Google
it's all about why should you even care
and why Vitality matters and how much
this is literally your rocket fuel to
anything else you're doing in life so it
was that psychology bit so that was fun
I probably wouldn't do it
on a daily basis and building something
to me is also
um
honestly you know being born there where
I was born Healthcare sucks and it still
does so I just want to almost like I
feel let me jump in Kevin Joe just give
me a 60-second warning
the number one thing you need to do
regardless of where we go with what we
just talked about is you need to figure
out what your
comfort zone is on communicating whether
that's the written word which it is
clearly not for me or Jennifer
right like the written writing wasn't
our output
in is it audio there's only three
there's audio video and word and this is
gonna be the answer for so many of us in
here
the question is which format works for
you and then what you need to do is
realize the following the number one
just this is going to work with you
because you're doing it for others
everything is about perspective shift a
slight perspective shift the number one
perspective shift that you have to make
sure you understand and it might not be
a shift it might come natural to you but
it is the punch line for what you're
about to embark on
you have to give away all your best
advice on social media at scale
right
so the the biggest things are a how do
you want to make content video written
word
audio
be the team here I put out tons of free
content will help after this like
figuring out which platforms right is it
YouTube shorts is it LinkedIn is it
Snapchat is it Twitter
and then you have to make sure that the
content that comes out of your mouth is
your best content
and you're basically saying the same 23
things
or four things four thousand times with
different contexts it becomes like hey
are you
the CEO of a 50 000 person Fortune 500
company blah blah blah blah the next
video is literally like hey are you the
you know leader of a small business with
nine employees you know what I mean so
it's about
distribution contextual format but the
biggest thing is the strategy of your
words has to be all your best advice too
many people like that fit your profile
hold back some of it because they think
that's the thing that people pay for the
people don't pay for that the people pay
for the when you get in there you're
really getting detailed to their reality
you can still stay top level but go into
very heavy detail on your advice got it
that is awesome that's fantastic thank
you so much Gary all right we're going
to Laura next
you're Mueller
okay thank you
um my question for you Gary is I've been
in business 12 years you know you and I
talked years ago when I was just a few
years into it I remember you telling me
at that point spend absolutely as much
as you can afford on Facebook and
Instagram ads and influencers and I wish
I had spent more at the time I did I
took your advice but I wish I would have
10 times that
um
and by the way it's important for
everyone here there's no worse feeling
than not squeezing
and orange as hard as you can when you
have unlimited oranges coming from the
tree because in this game you wake up
one morning and there's no oranges on
the tree
to Laura's point is really important for
cats and everybody like this is day
trading attention what I do for a living
is day trade attention you know knowing
what Ned was doing for a living and
knowing the places he was doing is like
he's been I don't know how much or how
little but like he's been aware of my
trajectory over the long period of time
at this point and so there's a reason
that I'm consistently there because it's
it's the obsession of understanding this
point and just so everybody hears this
because it's gonna be the theme for next
hour what Laura went through when she
did this before and probably why she's
back is it was right
and then it changes and it's not as good
of a deal anymore and you're like damn
it and then what's really and by the way
Laura you think you're upset it upsets
me because I'm like the Godfather of
this game and I don't squeeze it all the
way every time I promise myself
the next time I see it I'm gonna go eat
and I do and it's still never I still
never go hard enough because the value
is so high so I just wanted to call that
out for everybody because I'm pumped
that you've felt that and the reason she
said that is because if she went to go
do those same behaviors now it doesn't
work the same no
no and and my um just overall you know
notes to self.com has been the channel
That I focus the most on I also sell to
Hallmark stores Hospital gift shops
boutiques recently airports are big
expansion area for us and there's a lot
of potential there and we're getting
good traction there
um 12 years into it like you like just
what you said Gary that like more people
need to know about my brand like
everybody that knows about it loves it
you know best socks you'll ever wear
made in the USA people write me and give
me stories about how they're changing
their lives and what what are we trying
to figure out because I don't want to
run out of time I don't want to give you
as much as possible go ahead yeah I I
guess my question is like if you or me
what would you do next like part of me
feels like I didn't I didn't start the
company to sell it but I'm not going to
live to be 200 so I you know there's got
to be some kind of strategy and I think
I'm at the point where
like I I think I could help the world
more if I could grow faster and so
that's kind of
what's the top line revenue
a couple million and where's most of the
business coming from about half and half
you mean store and.com yes and on
the.com part where is most of the same
do you have a sense of where most of the
sales are coming from
Facebook ads and Instagram mostly
Facebook and I pay a lot I know you do
where do you pay and are you doing them
I am and that that's part of my thought
process this year
I mean I'm kind I'm doing it all tick
tock has to become incredibly important
to you like all that time and energy
that you're putting in your business
like
you know you need to send out like 25
packages of socks like a week
and know that like only one of the or
two of the 25 tick-tockers are actually
going to do anything about it but that
one tick tocker one time can actually
change the outcome of your business
it's actually
what influencer marketing looks like but
nobody wants to it's all the same game
everyone wants to look good but nobody
wants to go to the gym
you know like like you know it's just
that's what it is with business like
nobody wants to have the patience to do
the right marketing tactics for you it's
sampling to influencers with a very low
ratio of good things happening because
it's disheartening right I tell you you
have to send out 25 different packages
takes you two hours to find these people
a week on Tick Tock then you gotta
message them all most don't reply with
an address or they have you find the
address in their profile then you
then you send it most people don't post
like and becomes like disheartening
pretty quick yet four months in the one
right person thinks it's the cutest
thing ever makes a video two million
views and like now you do more Revenue
in 48 hours on those organic views than
you do on your entire Facebook spend on
the year
that's 2023. okay I just signed up for
that ltk you know like to know it
influencers
yeah I don't I'm not educated enough to
tell you I want you to do your own work
on it because I think what will happen
is if you do research in the trenches
you'll find the moms you'll find you'll
find your people right you'll find your
people plus what I like about you and
anybody who has a consumer business
spending an hour or two in Tick Tock is
you'll know what's happening in culture
and it will change your creative and it
will give you a pulse you'll most you
might also pick up on a line
you know a slang term or a sentence that
you put on a sock because you're in the
trenches that is the viral one that you
make like it's just good work
an hour day searching on Tick Tock and
getting good at that over the course of
a year is just good research work
thank you
you got it right let's shift over to Ned
Ned it's your your turn you're up
um so Gary over the last 10 years
um have built um the promotional
products business doing Brandon
merchandise for companies the business
is built but just to be completely
completely honest with you
um I don't I don't love it and it like
drains my energy and it's become and
it's a really hard thing for me because
I'm so grateful for it I have two young
kids it pays the bills but the 10 of my
time over the last handful of years that
I'm pitching to companies to say hey
you're not producing enough video
content let me come in be your social
media reporter interview staff interview
customers product reviews doing that
content it's consistently working but I
have no time during the day to do that
and build that
because there's so much business coming
in on the promotional product side and
I'm too afraid to make the higher of a
higher I know I have to make
and I've been talking to James for the
last you know year or two and he's like
we'll take out a business line of credit
that's like my like blood money and
there's twenty thousand dollars left the
business has never been hotter on both
sides but I've never been more
overwhelmed working day and night I
really want to let go of the logistics
of the all of these orders that are are
coming in and really focus on the
content again I know it's an and game
and I have to stop looking at these as
separate businesses potentially but what
I really want to ask is
how do I do I structure a deal with
somebody I pay part-time and maybe give
a percentage of sales like this is like
such a James and Gary love this problem
because we just like you do understand
that there's an unlimited amount of 24
year old uses in the world
I don't think I do I I'm like so I know
it goes back to that's what why this is
so [__] fun for me similar to what
Cass was saying about like what's fun
for her the high of like you're saying
[__] people know but it's amazing how
the words matter the semantics matter
the moment matters the context matters
like brother the amount ready for this
the now this takes work but it's the
work that gets you to a Finish Line
otherwise you're in a [__] hamster
wheel the amount of 24 year olds
that have pure talent and work ethic but
didn't get lucky enough to be born into
the right family or the right area of
the country or the right you know like I
always say that if I was a good student
I would own the Jets Nixon I always talk
about this to myself I don't say
publicly if I knew what an SPV was I
would have best beat Facebook four years
before IPO and I would have made it I
wasn't like if my roommates at Brown and
Yale and like all the things I've
learned about how the world Works my
life would have been on a different path
now I don't I'm so happy where I'm at I
can't even imagine to worry about those
things where I'm going with that analogy
is there's a 23 year old kid right now
that was born on the wrong side of the
tracks that will work for free for 10 of
equity of this company
for free man forget about minimum wage
now you're probably gonna have to do
minimum wage you probably have to do
maybe a little bit more but like I would
spend 100 of my time to find the person
to give 10 of the company to that had
almost no cost associated with them up
front and they had no equity until they
proved it over a year like I would
literally there's a lot of people
there's even people born on the right
side of the tracks that would take that
deal because they just want to be an
owner and they just like the business
and you know better to be owning 10 of
your business than being a logistics or
project manager at a company
you need to spend all your time dating
for your Junior partner
you know James thoughts on that
yeah when I was uh uh speaking with him
earlier and he was worried about being
cash strapped and everything we talked
about look just just get yourself some
breathing room right the time to get a
credit line is when you don't need a
credit line you and and he and he
deployed the money and used it well for
what a year and a half you've been you
know leaning more into your passion
project and I think it's more than 10 of
where you are right now but uh you know
it could have even been a client on the
other end I mean look you're the one
that sold us this so you know you have a
lot of a lot of clients that you uh that
you may have somebody who's taking the
orders with and back to being cash
strapped like you I mean you could
literally again I'll say it again there
is doing that work
there are a lot of 24 23 22 25 year old
talented people on earth
that you're offering them a better
opportunity at a close to minimum wage
minimum wage to 10 ownership is bananas
for a lot of people
especially like first generation you're
you're in Cali right now uh Michigan
outside of Detroit right like
even even better you have like [__]
unlimited kids graduating got hundreds
of thousands of 22 years coming out of
the system in a 40 mile radius 100 mile
radius of you
you know me University of Michigan or
Michigan State kids would literally do
this would literally take especially in
this environment where everyone wants to
be an entrepreneur
and yeah they would have normally taken
the 150 000 job in New York 20 years ago
and you and I were going up the game but
like today they'll literally take 20
bucks an hour to prove it for a year to
own 10 to do this very mundane
achievable work which is why it's
driving you crazy
got it I appreciate it on real quick if
I have one more minute look like I have
a humongous coconut that I'm about to
drink real quick so on on on my content
what you said a while ago about like you
call it like almost like being like the
digital like like become the mayor it's
like I'm so passionate about small
businesses here in Michigan that when I
go get a haircut I go eat a pizza I'm
like I would do that content for free
and that's my version of a podcast for
them and some of them now are turning
into to clients should I just quadruple
down on on that kind of content because
I don't need anything from my audience
like I'm not trying to get anything when
I post on social it's just like sparking
joy and man on the street and I mean
like that
yes the answer is yes because the
coolest part similar to me not wanting
anything from my audience it leads to
B2B Behavior right you're going to wake
up one day if you 8X that behavior and
you're gonna get an email from Visa
saying we're our big initiative is on
small businesses you know we we've been
scouring Detroit or Michigan as a pro is
a top five market for us where we need
it we think you're the face of this can
we JV together and you're getting a 250
000 a year ambassador to the Visa Small
Business program I mean it's it's a
humongous space
okay I appreciate it thank you thank you
thank you
let's see we're moving over to Chris and
Ethan up in New Hampshire hey guys
hey how we doing Gary the first thing
before I asked the question I just want
to say thank you for everything you've
done long time follower of your content
really instrumental in some of the
changes I've made in my life over the
years
um Joe and I were talking you know I've
been sober for five and a half years
it's made a huge difference in my life
there was a lot of things that that was
gone through beforehand
um but anyways a lot of your content was
responsible for that so I gotta thank
you
very excited for the fly fish Club to
open vf1 holder been at both the econs
anyways I'm gonna let Ethan ask the
first question because this is really a
lot of this is for him
um so I'm gonna let him ask the first
question just be quick I do have a
question okay so I'm 22. I I uh went to
school for a little bit went to college
a little bit didn't know what I wanted
to do I left I um I've been working for
him I started working in the field doing
the construction for about a year and a
half two years and now I jumped into
this marketing role in-house I have a
certificate through UVM in just the
basics of fundamentals of digital
marketing and my main focus right now is
on the creative aspect of what we're
doing we're going to be working with the
Sasha group as well and my main question
was as a 20 year old entering this
digital marketing slash creative content
space what skills do you think are going
to be the most needed within the next 5
10 15 20 years that I should focus on
learning there's a couple places you can
look at one is
This Acronym of pack platforms and
culture will never go away what are the
platforms that people pay attention to
today their social networks
they're streaming TV services obviously
we saw the Apple announcement Facebook's
working on it like VR is going to happen
in your lifetime so that would be a
platform people pay attention to and
then there's culture right who's ice
spice you know who's going to be the
number one pick in the NBA draft who's
you know all the stuff that's happening
in popular culture so you can make your
commitment to that
so you're great at understanding how the
algorithms work what are all the
different creative ways you can make
content you might know this like if you
go look at my Instagram you can see I
have all sorts of different ways I do
content right video characteristics
we're doing all sorts of different
so being great at that game or you could
become a prop engineer so AI is going to
completely eat up marketing during your
time and something that you should
Google is prompt engineering like what
you ask AI is going to be the punch line
right so like being good at asking
chat GPT mid-journey these things
questions is definitely a skill set that
I would focus on
okay
do you think AI is going to take over
the creative aspect of things or more so
paid SEO and those kind of things
I don't think it's gonna take over
either the way you're asking it when
everyone's like oh my God all the jobs
are gonna be fine like it's going to
become a compliment it will change [__]
but there's no absolutes there's people
that still have AOL do you know millions
of people use AOL dial up
like the world takes a long time to
adjust to everything so like it's it's
going to make a change in every area
Okay so cool so now
you know Jen and I don't have to hire a
writer to write our stuff you know chat
sheep he can do it first like it's also
like we're still gonna have to either us
ourselves or hire someone that's good at
asking chat GPT the questions you're
still going to have to conceptualize if
you're going to use mid-journey so you
may not hire someone to do Adobe
Photoshop but you still have to be great
at coming up with the idea to input so
prompt engineering okay thank you okay
so my quick question all right I'll try
and be quick about it so
27 years in Gary been running rescon
basement Solutions as the brand
um but have also been in love with why
be wet as a quick easy to remember kind
of tag
from a branding perspective what would
you do if if you were coming on board
have these two names which would what
would you do
well I think Nike and just do it are
both things that that company focuses on
okay so just kind of blend the two
together
I don't think it's that you blend like
this you know what that this is what
you'll like this this is when people go
into Academia versus real life
we're we're pondering the challenge here
when there is no challenge
like you don't need to blend them
together like you have a slogan that is
memorable
and you have a brand and a company name
that also should be built right okay so
it's just a game of and right like when
you say Blended together I have no
problem if the two of you put the slogan
in every piece of content
and I have no problem if you put the
slogan in half of the pieces of content
this is where I where I get into like
philosophy versus real life okay back to
him quitting college and like feeling
like when he said you know I I know his
psyche because I was his psyche when
he's like well I got a certificate from
like I'm like I don't give a [__] what
certificate you have from digital media
that certificate sucks [__] I promise
you that whatever they taught you in
that class was dog [__] I agree I paid
for it so I get it yeah
I've shipped in my mindset over the past
year after being by the way like me but
now that I'm out less and less I'm like
I I'm okay with it as another dude that
struggled with school I understand the
Journey of going from like thinking it's
a vulnerability or it's an issue to
realizing it means nothing and this is
kind of I'm bringing that back up
because same here there's no right way
to manage a brand and a slogan properly
there's just doing it right okay
pun intended right right
so that's it you don't have to you don't
have there is no right way just use them
both play with them both sometimes
together sometimes separate and just
keep going on feel okay Joe do I have
time for one more quick question
so it's a scaling question we're at 30
people
um I've capped out you know the core
people that have been with me for 10 15.
20 years I've gotten the growth that I
can out of them now I've got to really
hire some people and bring them on how
did you jump that shark to Bringing on
people and getting to that you know 50
100 person level and keep them trained
and maintaining that culture
by having
one-on-one conversations with the 30.
you know what to do your problem is the
30.
okay so spending more time with the 30.
spending more time with the 30 and
understanding you have 30 different
things going on there yeah no I know so
it's just spending more time with that
because you know four of them are going
to be upset
about like new people coming in and you
know three of them are going to suppress
the new people and try to [__] them up
because they don't want to take their
spots and you know five of them are
going to be sad when the new people come
in and become their bosses but you know
that they're not good enough and four of
them should be fired but they're your
family and you don't want to fire them
and
so you have to have one-on-one
conversations and you need to tell them
the following
from One By One The General theme is I'm
taking this to the next step because
that's my responsibility
right
in that I see
things are going to change somebody in
these next 20 is going to get hired
and maybe come your boss and you're
gonna think that's crazy because you've
been here for 17 years
and they've been here for three
I'm speaking to you because I actually
am okay with hiring no people but
everyone here now has families like same
thing happened to my dad's business you
can't work weekends you know like I need
Young Blood because you you're going
home at five o'clock and you're not
about you used to I could have you work
full-time on Saturday now I can't even
text you on Saturday without you giving
me attitude
right
right exactly yep got the 30
conversations to tell them what's
happening and 10 of them are going to
say actually [__] that [__] I'm ready to
step up and it may help you hire five
less people and 20 other people won't
get at won't have a leg to stand on when
they're upset with you because you have
the conversation right okay I can do
that okay all right let's go up there
[Music]
how's it going Gary good brother
yeah just to say real quick uh you're
you're a beast and uh you've influenced
us both in our our the culture of our
company so we appreciate that
um means a lot to me at a pivotal point
when we were 18 that's when we were
looking at your content and we could
have gone Steve Jobs or garyvee and we
went garyvee so yeah
I think I said that on the back of
somebody yesterday that works for our
company and it was my first one-on-one
with her and she broke down and cried
because she grew up in Tech and flat out
used the Steve Jobs and me analogy of a
turning point in what she sees and for
you to then bring it up complete when I
tell you the last time somebody used the
Steve Jobs and me and algae was like
five years ago and for that to be in
back to back days I love that kind of
kismic [__] because I because I really
believe in it and I'm pumped for you
guys because here's the AHA that nobody
understands you guys are going to make
more money and people can be happier
it's like a [__] win-win oh yeah
but um yeah in terms of uh of a question
so a little context so we've been using
we're at about a little over 2 million
in sales we've been using Facebook ads
we're like the only people in our area
that do it
um any you know remotely well
um we've seen like 10 15 more leads year
over year over year and then this year
all of a sudden boom we get half as many
leads uh coming in
um so we went from increasing 15 to
getting to pretty much half uh the
saving Graces we've been improving
operations and things like that and
we've had much higher close rates our
services better so our Tech's good our
operations good
um you know we're getting some tactics
from your team which has been awesome
go ahead go ahead go ahead I was saying
we're getting tactics from your team in
terms of like best utilization practices
of the the platforms which is huge
um and I feel like we're going to get
some more of that after this too so I
guess for my question goes with this is
you know so as much as you can put us
yourself in the shoes of a marketing
person who's trying to sell people on
cutting grass and keeping weeds out of
their lawn and I think I know where
you're going to go with it but
um what is what does garyvee do when he
steps in and walks
how big is the general area that you're
Marketing in so it's about 11 towns we
have about uh 50 to 60 000 homes we
think roughly just based off
um analysis so like I said we're at like
two we think we could be about three
times the size we are now in the same
area we also have the infrastructure to
support being about 50 bigger right now
um as a result of previous you know
um mistakes in terms of getting on
bringing on too much
um infrastructure so we have a lot of
room to go and we just we can't catch up
to ourselves fast enough so that's
that's what that's where we're at yeah I
think what's super interesting about the
Facebook thing is I think you're hitting
saturation point
it's not that Facebook's the problem
it's that your area you've just hit
saturation of how many people are paying
attention and the other saturation is
the creative
right so the creative is the variable
how many different pieces of creative
are you guys running
so right now for for in terms of AD we
would we would put up like maybe three
or four ads run them against each other
and every year we make new ones
um you know we've done things off your
advice like we've put Town names with
like the high school colors on there
that's improved it uh like we've done
all that tactical stuff but you're only
running three to four ads right right
per town so I obviously have 11 ad sets
and each one has three to four different
ads all pinned again with a per Town
contextual to the town so on just
Facebook tactics I want you guys to do
three to four new ads that are
completely different video and imagery
per Town per week
okay so you're talking like ads ran on
the platform like throwing in New pieces
of creative ad content running it as
like a conversion ad every week we love
that you'll love this brother the only
variable is the creative you're in a set
Target
right so one thing that was mentioned
previously was kind of like top of
funnel so we've done we've done a good
amount of organic like value posts like
look look out for this weeder here's how
you do a professional mulch Edge or
things like that
I love that how much
so my my question is is that could
should we I need you to answer that
answered me how much organic posting
you're doing probably like 10 of what we
do is probably organic posting I
probably post like once every two weeks
maybe yeah most of the focus is on paid
ads we don't I think we don't we haven't
done enough in the organic space because
we haven't had it right away right right
right up right off the top if you go to
Facebook real ads not just Facebook feed
sure
and you go to three to four variable
completely different I'm not talking
[__] font and colors I'm talking
about like flat out new commercials like
completely different [__] got it three
to four times three or four posts a week
changing you've got your last weeks so
basically think about it
the world used to do one post for the
whole year on Facebook this was real
talk when you guys were [__] in
diapers they were running one post for
the whole year
against all 11 towns and what you think
about you doing it you're doing four
posts a year
times 11 towns that's Monumental you've
got 44 different ads versus one right
I want you to do four ads I want you to
do 44 different ads a week
at the whole year and I want you to post
four times organically
a day
if you're asking should we put money
behind like so if we run like if we put
the when you say ads should some of
these ads not be geared towards
conversion
it's like should some of them just be
putting ourselves out there in terms
volume the first answer is volume the
second answer is do organic at scale and
if something goes viral turn it into an
ad okay and the organic stuff purely
just organic like you're just talking
like throwing up a reel on Facebook or
Instagram or a post just like a photo a
video of Nick walking a property just
like straight up no paid no nothing
YouTube shorts and Tick Tock in addition
to Instagram in addition to Facebook
Facebook reels is a monster go ham and
your you guys are at one percent on your
creative variable testing one percent I
want you to literally 52 x
what you're doing by changing the app
now when you find something that works
you now you're running five ads because
you kept one from the prior week that
you love
and you've added four new ones your
entire game is based on more creative
more creative ways to storytell more
creative ways organically more creative
ways to run ads
so you'd even advise still on like Tick
Tock and stuff like that even though
it's just posting to the world not
contextual or 10 times still be posting
on Tick Tock right that's right because
when you do something that's super aha
or like like makes sense then you're
gonna take it so the algorithm is going
to show you what people give a [__]
about
so if you're like 15 seconds on how you
can fix your lawn and then you go and
people like this is [__] insane well
now you just use the algorithm to give
you affirmation on Creative that will
work and then you run it as a [__]
Facebook ad that is with supported copy
and is being done as a performance ad in
Facebook and it's the best ad you've
ever run because you figured it out in
an organic Tick Tock because it has the
best interest algorithm okay so it's
like a testing thing like not
necessarily we're not looking for for
clients because obviously we can't
Target them into our you're gonna love
this it's a it's an insights thing that
also built top of the funnel awareness
for you right okay and that's yeah right
you guys have you guys have an awareness
issue because you're you're penetrating
you by the way all your ads that you're
running right now on Facebook in the
same style of just four different ads
that you've been doing for a while
nobody's seen that anymore
I'll tell you why because all the people
that you could get you got
right yeah it feels like of course
that's what's happening yeah you've hit
a saturation point now just by changing
your creative on Facebook you can get a
whole new world
okay but you start adding Tick Tock you
start adding you know YouTube shorts is
amazing because people search and you
might have a how-to like so that's
that's there's plenty of that content
it's just a matter of like all right
yeah one other question if I have a sec
um so one thing I noticed you do a lot
of is like you'll spend time and you'll
like you post about it so like you
change you know one word in a phrase or
something like that like these really
Nitty Gritty tests that you're doing on
organic posts for somewhat at our size
with our workload it's like would you
still suggest we try to get that granted
even with the ads like say we have you
know we start posting that often uh
obviously we're a b testing I'd love to
know what you're doing with your 12
hours a day
I mean that's that's a fair answer
I'm [__] a kid trying to build a big
ass business you should be working you
have the capacity to work 12 to 15 hours
a day and I'd love to know you're busy
you know I'd show me your calendar with
that said
love it though thank you Gary
David rapper we're not going to ask to
see your calendar but we are gonna have
to step up and talk to Gary I know how
it feels Gary I didn't put palantir in
an SPV in the early 2000s it hurts so
you live and you learn right right I've
got a bro I got a lot of those I know I
know I know I I've seen
um
so we have a good little business we're
at 400 million AUM so it's a small asset
manager it's all uh individuals they're
all like my family I do anything legal
for them I have everybody from Mark
lazri and Ken langone who let me say
their names so I'm not talking at a turn
to a dentist I treat them all equally
and they're they're literally like my
family so
um the quick you know why wouldn't I
want to grow it I want to have more
impact I want to do more
um
and so you know the bottleneck is
it's a very unique business right
because it's TR it's really big trust
right so it takes years to build trust
why would you give and why would you
give me money to manage when you can go
to Morgan Stanley or Fidelity or whoever
so it's it's really a long long long
sales cycle if it if it's even sales
it's it's mainly
someone saying you can trust Dave he's
good they've done really good for me and
you know people people turn you know
give up give us a portfolio to manage so
the question is does digital play a role
at all how would you know growth hacker
how would you how would you how would
you get from 400 to a billion under
management
by realizing that digital is how trust
is built it's how think about what's
happened in American politics it's all
been done by digital
right like people's entire perception is
based on communication the more you if
I'm you I'm doing Unlimited
video content on LinkedIn and YouTube
shorts because YouTube is a search
engine
YouTube shorts is a monster but this but
I think the way you do it is create a
format of a show and you interview
people okay contemporary Finance
contemporary event I love the I love
contemporary modern uh of the moment the
way you get people to pay attention in
your world in my opinion is giving them
the sense of
shit's changing
and that's where the Arbitrage is
and that's what this show focuses on
and my CEO's interview you know people
like that are in my network what do you
do right you that's right and by the way
once you have this is why I love this
once you have a podcast
I've watched Ray dalio
your Arthur Blank I've watched some of
the most iconic
business men and women do the most
random shows because the person cold
emailing them said the word podcast
hmm
I'd love to have you on my podcast to
talk about your journey you'd be shocked
many people will say yes to that
it goes back to what I talked to the you
know Nick and the boys just now on it's
are you gonna spend one hour on it a
week asking people to be on the show or
are you gonna ask try to do four hours
the way you do that is by having a 45
minute video weekly show where you
interview someone and you chop up
you know how I do my content I know I'm
I'm one of the most prolific content
producers in the world and I don't sit
down and make content I do my life
and then we post produce
your life in this scenario would be
spending an hour or two getting guests
because it takes time
and then spending an hour making the
show
and then spending another hour or two
cutting up the clips or you have
somebody do it if you know depending on
what you want to allocate to but that's
the five to six hours a week
that is required for you to do this well
okay
but in his podcast
YouTube LinkedIn [__] at scale like I
just said to the last boys like the only
difference between me is that calendar
you just saw and the output
all right and last but not least
Jennifer you're up
hi Gary so um a very short condensed
version of my history my former my late
ex-husband and I were the biggest on QVC
and we kind of just set the trend for
skin care on shopping networks
um we ended up getting divorced he kept
the business I kept the kids I left as
the largest shareholder and I used all
that funding to raise my kids because he
he wasn't much help um later on I was
doing you know small things on the side
Consulting working with small businesses
and I was working with a doctor he
wanted to start a skincare line and I
suggested hey I can I can do this for
you um because that's that's my
background it's my field so I'm kind of
tapped out like credit wise I've got all
my funds in this
um my partner ended up exiting he got
personal problems you know financially
and he gave me 100 of the business we
had launched on shop HQ because that was
my background
um we were doing great but they had like
payment issues so I got nervous about
their stability and had to leave so now
I have um 60 000 in inventory and
because I really can't do anything
funding wise I've been chasing after
these big influencers I got like really
close
to the point where she even liked one of
my comments about trying my product she
has my product I've been in talks with
her team how do I keep her attention
because if I can get a short hit like
that with you know an influencer that
could help me self-fund more to make it
back to QVC which is where I intend to
go but I need to do a 25 person clinical
study before I can get there so that's
why another reason why I was on the
small Shopping Network so I've got my
plan I'm going overseas I've got
somebody there who wants to place an
order but I really do need to get that
quick boost so do you have any
suggestions on without mentioning it you
know because she's not answering my
emails how can I keep her attention and
keep her interested
I think first of all there's a lot of
high risk with that the thought of her
or anybody else posting and that
guaranteeing the sales of those units is
not there right but just to review just
where they say they like your product
when when they say they they like they
like your product what do you mean one
more time I want to make sure I
understand so a lot of these big
influencers what they do is they just
take your product they try it and
they're like oh wow you know I had a
great experience I got results and boom
they move on to the next one that's
really all I need is just to kind of get
known out there I'm going to say it
again Mike I'm very aware of influencer
marketing I'm talking about
I'm not sure that would work oh okay
well I do this for a living at scale
right like
like take a Vanderpump right now that
which is top of mind for everyone that
post saying I like this does not
guarantee the product sell it's
happening all the time that where that's
not happening my and my biggest concern
is that you see that as the lightning
bolt to give you the quick pump to get
you out of this situation to your next
thing and you may end up
going for that betting the whole Farm on
that and then not working yeah
that makes sense I'll just say this very
well like just back to everything's
friend yay here
putting up your product and saying I
love this coconut you should buy it may
not sell the units you think right
that's true what about um go ahead go
ahead like Mary Ruth Organics for
example you did something with them to
do creative funding do you think I'm a
candidate to do something like that and
how do you even approach something like
that why why wouldn't you just start
making content with yourself just like
what you were doing on QVC but just
doing it on all the social media
platforms yourself I was going and now
I'm going to start but I couldn't until
I hit a thousand followers so and that
was hard to get to why why couldn't you
do that until you why couldn't you make
content about your product until you had
a thousand dollars it wouldn't let me go
live but I've been making videos
yeah well right to me the point is like
for me
I think it's more about sending samples
to emerging influencers okay and not
paying at all
right if you send a sample of your
product to somebody has 30 000 followers
but is doing really good work on Tick
Tock right now they're one post away
from doing more than what you thought
you would do right okay so stick with
the smaller micro a hundred percent you
look because you were affected by your
career being built in those big moments
like you I'm very aware of what QVC and
shopping network has been historically
like like what's happening now is like
you don't want to bet a business model
on the on the lightning bolt model you
want to build it on the Brick by Brick
Brick by Brick back to like health and
wellness I don't want you looking for
like apple cider vinegar or like
the [__] shot I want you to put in
the work on eating and going to the gym
that in our world in what you do is
making four to five pieces of social
media content a day
okay which is what I've been doing okay
great and then what about um the Mary
Ruth model how did you do that like is
am I a candidate to do something like
that or Mary Ruth reached out yes you're
a candidate if you put out good content
for a decade then people like Mary Ruth
and everybody else in the world will
reach out to you
thank you you're welcome all right thank
you very much bye everyone